she sells seashells by the seashore red
leather yellow leather
unique new york she stood upon the
balcony
i am a mother pheasant plucker i pluck
mother pheasants
i am the most pleasant mother pheasant
plucker that ever plucked a mother
pheasant okay so we all know that tongue
twisters are really fun
and that they're fun because they're
hard and they make you mess up a boxy
biscuit biscuit book truly really
proper cough copper coffee butt but why
are they hard
today i'm going to walk you through why
some tongue twisters are more difficult
than others
so one of the things that we forget
sometimes is that speech sounds
are physical actions let's look at an
ultrasound image
of how many cans can a canner can of
counter can cans
how many cans can a canner can if a can
or can can
cans so here's a diagram of the inside
of your vocal tract this is called a
mid-sagittal section
and it's going to let us show really
clearly what some of these actions are
if we want to make a speech sound like a
p like a
pa right we're going to close the lips
here
the air is coming up through the vocal
tract and it gets stopped and then air
pressure builds up
until it explodes out in a pa you can
feel that if you try it yourself
try this a box of biscuits a box of
mixed biscuits and a biscuit mixer
try that three times fast a box of
biscuits a box of mixed biscuits and a
biscuit mixer
a box of biscuits a box of mixed
biscuits and biscuit mixer a box of
beasts a box of missed biscuits and a
biscuit mixer
a box of biscuits a box of mixed
biscuits and a big skit mis
mixer box a biscuit a box of mixed
biscuits and a biscuit mixer
we've got these same two consonant
sounds but we keep swapping the order
right
make a sound
here what's happening is that you're
bringing the back of your tongue
up to seal off the oral cavity
right there at the roof of your mouth so
just like with
right the air is getting stopped some
pressure is building up and then we're
releasing it forward
if i were to make a s sound like a long
s sound
i'm going to bring part of my tongue
usually for most of us anyway it's going
to be your tongue tip i'm going to bring
my tongue tip up towards this gum ridge
here
then the air is going to have to fight
to get past this narrow little
obstruction that i've made here
and the sound is coming from the
turbulence of the air trying to get past
that obstruction
now say the english word box
so the back of your tongue has to be up
here for the
and then it has to come down and the
front part of the tongue has to come up
real quick as to flip up for this
box has to happen really fast but so far
so good we do that all the time no
problem
box on its own no problem box box box
biscuit on its own no problem biscuit
biscuit biscuit we can do that all day
long
a box of biscuits a box of mixed
biscuits and a biscuit mixer
we keep swapping the order
that's what makes it hard a box biscuits
a box of mixed
biscuits and a biscuit biscuit mixer a
box of biscuits a box come miss
fixes and a big biscuit mixer a box of
beasts
biscuit book a box of biscuits
a box of biscuits a box of mixed
biscuits biscuit mixer so there's been
some cool research into tongue twisters
where they put people in brain imaging
machines and had them do tongue twisters
to try to study the way planning works
in speech and one of the things that
they've been able to confirm
is that speech sounds are organized in
the brain according to the physical
actions and where they take place in the
vocal tract so
there are tongue twisters that tend to
make us mess up
in similar consonant sounds and tongue
twisters that tend to make us mess up
vowel sounds
let's talk about the immortal tongue
twister toy boat
go ahead and try it first three times
fast toy boat toy boat toy boat
all right this one's easier toy boat toy
boat toy boat toy boat toy boat
toy boat ten times fast toy boat toy
boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boy
to help explain this one i'm going to
pull up a quadrilateral you may have
seen me bring up the vowel space in a
previous video
it's basically a person facing to the
left like this we're in a cross section
the front of the mouth is over here
back of the mouth is over here it's a
map of the inside of your mouth and it
lets us be really precise
about the exact shape and position of
the tongue inside the mouth for a given
vowel sound
so both of these vowel sounds in the
words toy and boat
in most accents of english they're
diphthongs they start in one spot
and they move to another so we can draw
them on the vowel chart in my accent
oy starts way back here oh
and moves forwards and up e
so the whole thing goes
it's a big old journey o is a much
smaller journey but it
is kind of similar in that it also
starts way in the back
and then it's going to move up and
forwards ooh
obviously this comes in a million
different flavors different accents
let's just stick with mine for now
[Music]
you see how these are parallel they have
a very similar movement pattern
the lips however are starting from very
rounded in
[Music]
and then going unrounded and they're
doing the opposite of that
in o in that vowel in both they're
starting off
not very rounded and they're moving into
lip rounding
so it's a coordination problem again
you're moving your tongue in a really
similar way from back to front and up a
little for both of them
but you're having to move your lips in
opposition to that toy boat
toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat so
you very quickly get confused
toy boat toy boat toy boy toy boat toy
boat toy boat toy boat toy
i mentioned by the way that the o vowel
sound what we call the goat
vowel has a lot of different varieties
in different accents of english
if we were to take a kind of an estuary
english accent for instance and i had a
vowel sound something like oh
boat that's going to look like this it's
going to start back here a little lower
and it moves more than mine did and it
moves but it still moves up and forward
it's still moving up and forward in that
general direction and moving from less
slip rounding
to more lip rounding and same is true
even more broadly true from further back
to further front
if i'm say doing a broad australian
accent i
toy boat here are some more people doing
toy boat toy boat toy bike toy bike toy
bike
toy boat toy boy toy boat toy boat toy
boat toy boat tour boy
toy boat toy boat toy boat
some time twisters are gonna be harder
for native speakers of some accents than
others let's take the fast thief flash
fried
thick fish the fast flash fight big fish
the fast bee flash fried thick fish the
fast the flash fried cake fish
the flower fast thief flashed fried
thick fish the festive fresh flash flag
thick fish this has got f
which is a labiodental sound lip and
teeth
and th sounds so the tongue tip coming
to the back
of the front teeth or maybe even in
between the teeth
like that thick the fast
thief flash fried thick fish the fast
the flash
fried thick fish so if we're gonna
alternate back and forth between them
then we have to go
the fast thief
flash fried thick fish
now if you're a speaker of an accent
that fronts th
sounds meaning instead of using your
tongue tip in the teeth
you use something more to the front of
the vocal tract like your lip going to
your teeth like this
so a word like thief you'd be inclined
to use
thief thief that too is going to be a
tricky coordination exercise
the fast beef flash fried thick fish
fast food flash fire thick fish
the fast fee flash fried fish fish the
fast
fif flash fried fish thick
next tongue twister truly rural purely
plural
well this is gonna be hard for just
about anybody truly rural purely plural
truly really
truly rural purely plural truly moral
purely
truly rural purely plural
but it's probably going to be harder for
americans than it is for
other non-north american speakers of
english truly rural purely plural
truly royal purely plural truly rural
purely plural gosh
that's hard to do one reason of course
is that there's just an extra r
in it if you're a non-rhodic speaker
then purely
it doesn't have an r sound in it at all
truly rural purely plural if you're a
rhodic speaker purely it's got one extra
r that's one extra r to mess up on
truly real clearly blurable
the other reason though is that american
molar
r er is particularly
weird i've talked about it before the
weirdest thing is that the sides of the
tongue
are sort of coming up you can imagine
kind of if i'm a tongue
and i'm raising my shoulders the sides
of those tongue will come up and they'll
make contact
with the upper teeth the molars and the
bicuspids on either side you can have a
really strong version of that where they
come
all the way up inside and even press out
against the sides of the upper teeth
here's an ultrasound of someone making
an american molar r
round and round the rugged rocks the
ragged rascal ran
now this is exacerbated because
americans also tend to use
a lot of back of tongue bunching on l
sound so that's the back of the tongue
coming up and back like this
but again kind of squishing back into
itself maybe in a sort of a similar way
to the way it's doing with r
up in here truly rural purely
purely plural
so here's a silly sentence that i just
wrote bossy tommy shaw
often called on lots of tall honest law
officers and constables to do all kinds
of
awful horrible profitless jobs bossy
tommy shaw often called on lots of tall
honest law officers and constables who
do all kinds of awful horrible
profitless jobs so that's not
necessarily a tongue twister for me
an american there are a few shades of
different vowels in there but it's not
necessarily going to trip me up but this
is going to be a nightmare
for a bread an australian a south
african basically any non-north american
who's trying to do an american accent
because there are
pattern shifts all over the place the
patterns of the vowels are different
bossy tommy shaw often called unless at
all on his law offices often called on
lots of tall
honest law officers and constables to do
all kind of awful horrible prophets jobs
for me the vowel sounds in bossy
bossy bossy and tommy tommy tommy tommy
are close but they're not the same
bossy tommy bossy tommy bossy tommy
whereas if i'm saying our peace speaker
bossy tommy they're both going to be
about here bossy told me she was he told
me bossy told me conversely the sounds
in
for me shaw and often
are the same they're right about here
shaw often shaw often
i think whereas if i'm a brit then that
might be sure
and often they're different you're often
sure of them sure often so that's really
going to make your brain explode
so i wrote this sentence as practice for
coordinating
difficult vowel sounds in an american
accent for
actors who aren't americans bossy tommy
shaw often
caught on lots of taller on this little
off floor
lore
okay next tongue twister if you're an
american try this
in your best rp all i want is a proper
cup of coffee
made from a proper copper coffee pot tin
coffee pots and iron coffee pots they're
no use to me
if i can't have a proper cup of coffee
made from a proper copper coffee pot
i'd rather have a cup of tea all i want
is a proper cup of coffee
made from a proper cough copper coffee
pot
tin coffee pot and iron coffee pods than
are used to me
if i can't have a proper cup of coffee
made from a proper cup of coffee pot i'd
rather have a cup of tea
oh my god for me all
uses a vowel sound up here and coffee
uses pretty much that same vowel sound
whereas proper
and pot are going to use a vowel sound
down here they're close but they're not
the same
we have a different pattern though in
our p so
all is going to be up here whereas
coffee proper and pot are all going to
be down here
so it's pattern shifts that make that
one really devilishly tricky but also
really good practice
oh proper proper proper coffee coffee
coffee pot
pot
in 2013 some researchers at mit came up
with what they claimed was
the hardest tongue twister in the
english language and this tongue twister
was so hard
that apparently none of the test
subjects could even get through it the
tongue twister is as follows
pad kid poured curd
pulled cod had kid poured curd pulp
caught
that kid poured curd pulled cod pad kid
poured curb pulp cod pad kid poured curd
pulled cod what does that mean
pad kid poured perk
so let's look at the first and last
consonants of each word first
each word ends in a d sound which is a
tongue tip sound
like this and they alternate they go
back and forth they're beginning
constants between
for the lips and for the back of the
tongue
so we have a lip sound a tip of the
tongue sound
da and a back of the tongue sound and
they're all stops they're all the same
kind of obstruction of airflow if we say
them all together
but just the consonant sounds that begin
in any word we get
could put could put could for even
pattern
put could put could put could let's look
at the vowel sounds now
so these go ah
[Music]
or er
we're kind of going all over the whole
vowel space here they're all different
we're not repeating any of them
so maybe that's what's hard about it is
that we're going back to the same
pattern over and over and over again
with the consonants
could whereas we're varying each of the
vowels and we never come back to the
same one so the combination of similar
and different could trip you up i guess
try it for yourself
see what you think pad kit board cut
pulled cord pad kid poured curled
curd pulled cod pad cake pulled cord
porch card
pack yield per cardboard kit packet port
card pulled pog
code
i've said it before speech is one of the
most physically complex things we do
as human being and of course it's
physically complex and it's complex in
terms of brain
planning and coordination so that's the
intersection
that makes tongue twisters so
fascinating and difficult and fun
next time you do some tongue twisters
maybe just pay attention to what those
physical actions are and if you want to
try to pattern them
you can pattern the physical actions
after each other and get better and
better at coordinating them